why do you think he did it
so here is it madness or is it no it's
not strategic calculation perhaps
this one i cannot answer you faithfully
because
first of all we don't know what he was
told if he was indeed getting the right
intelligence estimates
from what i said earlier in that art and
that
in that essay i wrote
you would think
he was not well informed perhaps about
the degree
of
cooperation he would get from the russia
the ukrainian russians
in in in in ukraine i that would be one
factor that he wasn't
he didn't assess the operation correctly
remember this mr putin has had
this cancer
and he's i think he's licked it but he's
also been isolated because of covet
and some people would argue that the
isolation from
normal activity which he was he was
meeting people face to face but all of a
sudden he was meeting people across the
table uh a hundred yards away or
whatever 10 yards away it was very hard
to perhaps he lost touch
with contact with people so it's not
just power it's the very simple fact
that you're just this i'm speculating i
don't know i see that and i also
perhaps he thought in his mind that
there would be a
a faster resolution that the ukrainian
because the evidence had been that the
ukrainian uh russians
the ukrainian army had folded so many
times in the
and that they were only backed up and
they were stiffened by the resistance of
the nazi or
nazi oriented as of battalions that was
a factor of course and that is a big
factor for the russians because
these people are very tough they rush
see
what people don't understand is that
ukraine since 20 2014 has been a terror
state
and they've been run you know any time a
ukrainian has expressed any
uh any uh understanding of a russian of
the russian ukrainian position they've
been threatened by the state from 2014
to 2022 there's been a set of hideous
murders that people don't even know
about in the west journalists
people who speak out liberals
people who uh i i interviewed victor
medvedev who they make out to be some
kind of horrible person but medvedev was
this was very important figure in the
administration of kushma the first
ukrainian prime minister in the 1990s
and he did a great job on the economy he
was a very thoughtful man if you'll see
my interview it's called ukraine
revealed he's very thoughtful about the
future of ukraine he doesn't want to go
back and join russia he wants it to be
an independent country ukraine is
independent and he wants it to be a
functioning
economic democracy more or less a
democracy if you can get that but
between
that exists in a neutral state a neutral
state which ukraine used to be before
2014 it was neutral from 1991 to 2014
neutral very important
under uh poroshenko it just immediately
went into an anti-soviet cold war
position
as an ally of the united states
and
uh
my point was that
it was a very dangerous place in ukraine
i you people were being killed
death squads were out there
medvedev
they stripped him of his television
stations very suddenly this is olenski
the new president said he zoliskey was
elected on a peace platform remember
that he was 70 of the country was for
him to make peace with russia he did he
ever have even tried to make peace with
russia did he attend any of the minsk
two um agreements did he did he visit
did he pay any attention to putin did he
go to russia no not at all the moment he
got into office i'm convinced that the
the uh
the uh militant
uh uh the militant sector of the right
sector parties of the uh of ukraine let
him know that you will not make a deal
with russia
there'll be no concessions to russia
this is very dangerous this is where
this attitude that's very very hostile
to russia has hurt us the whole world is
being hurt by this and no no one calls
them out
no one calls them out zelensky backed
off
from his platform as a running for
president and as president has been
ineffective did nothing to promote on
the contrary went the other way and
seemed to support the uh the ukrainian
aggression
well he found his support in this war
you've revealed through your work some
of the most honest and dark aspects of
war
nevertheless this is a war and there's a
humanitarian crisis
millions of people as uh
refugees escaping ukraine what do you
think about the human cost of this war
initiated by it's horrible whoever
just as you write
whatever the context whatever nato
whatever pressure
as you wrote
russia was wrong to invade
okay yeah
let's get back to the original question
you said what was he thinking at that
time we never answered that yeah now
by the way uh you know
among those people who are
who've been
ruined by this war you have to include
the fort 2014 to 2022 yes ukrainian
russians fourteen thousand
uh
were killed not necessarily by uh
some of them by maybe accident this and
that but certainly a large number of
that is is responsible to the ukrainian
military and the uh the nazi-related
battalions who have done a good job of
death squading that whole area and
remember i did a film about salvador i
know a little bit about death squads and
how they work and i know about
paramilitaries because in south america
they're all over the place america
supports
hates venezuela goes on about venezuela
do they tell you anything about colombia
it's next door neighbor colombia for
years has been plagued by paramilitaries
that are right wing and the united
states has said nothing about them
except occasionally there's a newspaper
report now so this is a
this support of death squads by the
united states is all over the world it's
not just in south america and central
america where we see plenty of evidence
of it
it's here too and this is what's
horrible about this whole thing this
hypocrisy of america that they can
support such evil such evil now going
back to your
larger question about
uh yes it's a terrible refugee disaster
but again we have to get the numbers
let's get the numbers and get evidence
because
i i would ask you i'm not sure at this
point whether more civilians were killed
before 2022 in donbass than have been
killed in this latest so we can't talk
about this without we can't talk about
the invasion ukraine without considering
the full war between russia and ukraine
since 2014. that's correct absolutely
and
take the toll on both sides and you
might be surprised by the result
uh i think the russian military of
course i'm not there and i'm not this
could be this is speculation the russian
military has slowed down and part of
that reason is not to keep the civilian
corridors open and i think the ukrainian
military has made it more difficult on
purpose especially some of these
battalions that are death squad
battalions have gone out of their way to
keep the civilians locked into these
cities in danger because it's in their
interest to do so
so there's no reason why ukrainian
military who have killed ukrainian
civilians for years would change their
policies
they would have no compunctions about
wiping out for example people with white
armbands in bucca
okay
as to what putin was thinking at the
time i
i wondered this and i still do i said
okay so putin can say
one let's say uh the ukrainian
government wants to now invade donbass
this is on february 23 and they have
artillery they're peppery in the whole
place they're going to go in and they're
going to get don bass back
what do you do
and you you have russian uh separatists
who are russian ukrainians who are on
who
are going to fight
how far do you go in supporting them can
russia at this point say well we can't
help you you have to get along you have
to somehow you have to be absorbed by uh
they kev you're going to be absorbed by
them and they're going to be
they're not going to give you autonomy
and you have to live with them
and there's going to be a price to pay
you could do that and you can also say
well we open our borders to don't ask
you can come into our country you can
leave
and we will help you to to resettle
and that's that would be a reasonable
approach so you take it to the next
stage as putin's thinking you take it to
the next stage you
you stall
it's harder for your people of course
there's pressure on putin from inside
his own government
to say what are you going to do i mean
you can't do this there's a lot of
nationalists in russia they would
certainly bring he it would be to his
they'd say putin is weak and that's the
biggest rap you can ever give a russian
leader is you're weak you can't get
anything done
so there would have been some damage but
let's say he goes with that and he says
okay we know what the united states
intention is it's to
get rid of me regime change and to get
another yeltsin in that's what they want
and they will go to any ends they will
destroy ukraine if necessary but they
want regime change in russia and then
after they do that of course they'll go
after china but that's the ultimate
policy of the united states this is a
country that has no compunctions about
going all the way
and it will use hypocrisy in all the
news propaganda in the world to get what
it wants this is the equivalent frankly
of
germany's
goals in world war ii uh world
domination there's no question in my
mind but
we're going about it in our way as
opposed to hitler's way
so just to finish your thought where do
they go
what's stage two okay you let's say they
take ukraine takes back donbass
let's say people get killed in in large
quantities
so we now to the next stage we're
finished with the minsk two agreements
that were never adhered to so what does
russia do they wait for the next
aggression
which is going to come in one form or
another
perhaps in georgia perhaps i don't know
what would happen what the us is
thinking but they would have the u.s
cannot say
uh russia is has done anything they have
not used violence to stop donbass from
belonging back to
ukraine right so
you're in a new setup now it's a whole
thing rearranges
now you have but you still have nuclear
weapons
and you still have a russian
nuclear weapons and they're serious
weapons they're very well developed
crude but not as refined as the american
nuclear force but
powerful
that becomes another game then you open
another chess board and no one you still
haven't been condemned the sanctions
haven't been imposed that's a new it's a
new game
could he have done could have lived with
that that's the question i ask myself
you